bonsoir le 7-8 l'actus sur tv fil 78
nous sommes le 30 mai le journal de la
rédaction avec elle à suivre les images
des bleus qui se prépare toujours pour
le mondial de football dans les yvelines
et puis une compétition de golf
solidaire à saint quentin en yvelines ce
sera ce week end en seconde partie
comme chaque vendredi nous reviendrons
sur les principales actualités de la
semaine une semaine très politique
mais tout d'abord cette information
concernant la caisse primaire
d'assurance maladie les yvelines une
enquête pénale vient d'être ouverte
après la plainte dans des agents qui
dénonce les agissements de responsables
du comité d'entreprise
ces derniers auraient financé achats
d'ordinateurs de téléphones portables ou
encore voyages au soleil avec les fonds
du comité d'entreprise mais aussi de la
mutuelle de la sécurité sociale
yvelinoise elle les principaux accusés
de leur côté parle de réglement de
comptes sans aucun fondement
après leur belle victoire face à la
norvège au stade de france mardi soir
les bleus sont retournés dans notre
département à clairefontaine pour
continuer leur préparation en vue du
mondial de football qui se déroulera je
vous le rappelle à partir du 12 juin
prochaine étape d'ici là dimanche la
france affronte le paraguay à nice
reportage depuis le centre
d'entraînement des bleus dans les
yvelines
anthony rech face à la norvège l'équipe
de france a une nouvelle fois offert un
festival de buts sous la houlette de
didier deschamps
les bleus ont réappris à gagner ce large
succès ouvre la porte à l'enthousiaste
mais le staff de l'équipe de france sait
d'où il vient
le danger c'est pas de tempérer après
quand ça va bien ça va pas très bien et
quand ça va mal ça va pas très mal je l'
ai déjà dit je vous le redis donc oui il
faut rester lucide
être conscient de ce qu'on fait on fait
de bonnes choses mais on a encore
beaucoup de choses à faire et ce
festival de buts a été largement
orchestrée par mathieu valbuena très
critiqué cette saison pour ses
performances avec l'olympique de
marseille
le meneur de jeu des bleus a fait taire
toutes les critiques face à la norvège
avec trois passes décisives
moi je fais mon boulot sur le terrain
j'ai la confiance d'un entraîneur j'ai
la confiance de mes coéquipiers
après oui je sais que rien n'a été
évident mais ça sera tout le monde ma
carrière ça ça va pas s'arrêter donc
après et je sais si ce qui fait ma force
donc pour moi rien n'est acquis dans le
dans le football et je sais de quoi je
parle donc après je continue mon
bonhomme de chemin j'essaie d'apporter
de le plus possible à l'équipe de france
grâce à cette performance de choix
combiné aux grands matches d'olivier
giroud les bleus ont prouvé qu'ils
peuvent fonctionner sans leur leader
naturel après quelques autographes
franck ribéry les champions d'europe
benzema et varane ont d'ailleurs été
ménagé lors de l'entraînement ce jeudi
prochain test au complet dimanche à nice
face au paraguay
l'actualité sportive chargée en ce
moment entre le football et le tennis
avec elle les internationaux de roland
garros est d'où d'ailleurs plutôt au
foot plutôt tennis c'est notre question
du jour micro-trottoir coupe du monde de
foot c'est dans la famille plus roland
garros pourquoi je préfère le tennis
comme que le foot c'est plus plaisant
je trouve à voir que le foot ouais je
préfère le foot au tennis et ça bouge un
peu plus à l'ambiance des stades et de
tout ce qui va autour koala la folie
populaire les deux voilà parce que
j'adore le foot et j'adore le tennis
roland garros et coupe du monde c'est un
peu voilà pas trés trés football couvert
le tennis est ma passion coupe du monde
parce que je suis fan de foot + coupe du
monde ce que je préfère le foot je suis
pas trop fan de tennis coupe du monde
parce que je veux suivre attentivement
la france de roland garros je suis
vraiment jamais vraiment intéressé à ce
tournoi parce que je suis pas trop
tennis au départ la coupe du monde de
foot
on a tellement rêvé en 98 que ça nous
ramène un peu à ce rêve qu'on aimerait
bien re découvrir la france entière
sport et solidarité à présent le lion
sport action prépare la 11e édition de
son grand trophée ce sera samedi 31 mai
au golf de saint quentin en yvelines les
fonds récoltés iront une nouvelle fois
directement aider les enfants malades
écouter frédéric brousse c'est
l'organisateur de l'événement c'est une
compétition de golf qui chassèrent dans
un dispositif national qui le grand
trophée de l'ange club qu'on fait cette
année pour la onzième fois consécutive
c'est à ce jour la plus grande
manifestation de la plus grande
compétition de golf amateur en france
bien sûr elle est enregistrée auprès de
la fédération
c'est une compétition strictement
amateurs donc il n'y a pas de
professionnels dans cette compétition
ici tout vert à tout golfeur quel que
soit le niveau le green fillette à 50
euros et le droit de compétition est à
15 euros essayer ce sont ces 15 euros
qui sont reversés intégralement au
bioscope les fonds collectés sont
reversés intégralement à une association
qui s'appelle enfance et santé qui se
donnait pour mission de lutter contre la
leucémie et l'arroser de cancer chez les
enfants les adolescents les golfeurs
paler une fille le droit de compétition
nous est reversée intégralement par par
les golfs et c'est cet argent qui est
collecté abondé selon les cas par nos
sponsors et nos partenaires est reversée
intégralement
à l'association enfance et santé donc en
disant nous avons pris cette
manifestation a permis de collecter un
peu plus de 2 millions d'euros pour
l'instant qu'un enfant qui est
hospitalisé pour un cancer quel qu'il
soit ce sont des hospitalisations
longues et le bien-être des enfants
passe par la présence des familles donc
il est nécessaire d'avoir des
infrastructures il pouvoir les
accueillir pour qu'elle reste auprès des
enfants malades ce que l'hôpital ne peut
pas toujours proposé pour nos charges
nous allons à présent comme chaque
vendredi revenir sur l'actualité de la
semaine une semaine qui a débuté par les
résultats aux européennes en france le
front national l'a emporté et on verra à
24 députés au parlement dans le détail
en ile de france l'ump en revanche
plutôt bien résisté la liste d'alain
lamassoure est arrivé en tête sur le
département des yvelines
même constat mais en revanche c'est
l'effondrement du parti socialiste qui
est plus nette
comment avez vous voté sur votre commune
le point avec ce sujet de quatre nuls à
dos le fn premier parti attrape après
ces élections européennes de peu mais
c'est inscrit dans le marbre le front
national réalise 18 60% des voix
en 2009 le parti frontiste n'avait
obtenu que 4 60% des suffrages un
résultat d'autant plus regardées à la
loupe que c'est dans cette ville
socialiste que siègent notamment en
qualité de conseiller municipal
le ministre de l'éducation nationale
benoît hamon le parti de marine le pen
devance de quelques voiles la liste
socialiste et la liste front de gauche
l'ump est le quatrième parti à noter
également que seulement 25% des
électeurs trappistes se sont déplacés
aux urnes
le fn qui arrive en seconde position à
la verrière avec 17,7 pour cent des voix
derrière la liste front de gauche
couleur politique du maire sortant le ps
est troisième l'ump 4e en 2009 le front
national n'avait réalisé que 3,49 % des
voix une surprise à magny les hameaux
villes socialistes l'ump arrive en tête
avec 16 points 64% des voix talonné par
le ps 16 34% par contre pas de surprise
à elancourt au l'ump réalise 25,49 % des
voix le maire de la commune jean michel
fourgous était septième sur la liste
d'alain lamassoure mais le résultat du
parti
dans la circonscription de l'île de
france ne lui permet pas d'être élu
seuls quatre députés ump iront à
strasbourg les autres communes de
l'agglomération conservent leur couleur
politique à guyancourt c'est le parti
socialiste qui arrive en tête avec 18
40% des voix devant l'ump le fn et la
liste udi modem à montigny le bretonneux
la ville du divers droite michel laugier
l'ump réalise 20 77% des suffrages
devant la liste udf modem
même cas de figure à voisins le
bretonneux la commune avait été emporté
en mars dernier par l'ue dei alexandra
rosetti le parti centriste réalise 21 02
% des suffrages devancé de deux points
par l'ump le front national réalise plus
de 12% des voix là où en 2009 il n'avait
même pas atteint les 2% voisins le
bretonneux qui remporte la palme du
civisme pour l'agglomération plus de 50%
des électeurs inscrits se sont déplacés
aux urnes au tour de saint quentin en
yvelines a noté que l'ump confirme son
ancrage anouk pas la ville auparavant
divers gauche avait basculé à droite aux
municipales de mars
même cas de figure à bois d'arcy où
l'ump fait plus de 23 % des voix contre
12% pour le ps dans ces deux villes
auparavant à gauche
à noter la forte progression du front
national qui arrive en seconde position
un fn également sur la deuxième marche
aux clayes-sous-bois à saint cyr l'école
et à coignières reléguant le parti
socialiste comme troisième formation
dans ces communes dans les yvelines
globalement l'ump reste majoritaire avec
24 86% des voix s'est toutefois dix
points de moins qu'aux dernières
élections européennes de 2009
le front national le second partie du
département avec 17,77 % des suffrages
en 2009 la liste d'hubert dubois n'avait
seulement totalisé 3 95%
c'est donc le grand gagnant de ces
élections lui dénient modem et troisième
et le parti socialiste 4e avec 11 89%
des voix
une consolation pour la formation de
gauche en 2009 dans les yvelines
harlem désir n'avait seulement réalisé
que 11 60% des voix
un perdant dans le département europe
ecologie les verts
en 2009 la liste menée par daniel cohn
bendit avait totalisé 19 58 % des voix
cinq ans plus tard la liste verte
non
sorte que 7 64% des suffrages le front
national qui malgré son succès
s'interroge encore sur les raisons de
son résultat dans les yvelines le
responsable départemental du parti par
ailleurs candidat en ile de france ne
cache pas sa déception du tournoi marie
le pen dans les yvelines ont avec deux
points d'écart avec le fait national à
peu près ces derniers temps on était
monté à 3 ou 4 on ne vit pas d'avoir
quatre points d'écart ce qui était déjà
pas satisfaisant pour moi mais là on est
passé à 7 quand on est passé à sept
points d'écart par rapport donc un au
score national on a dit c'est que le
score national est à 24 7 points d'écart
et là ça devient carrément inquiétant
encore est ce que c'est le discours de
nine qui convient pas aux catégories
socioprofessionnelles des yvelines s'est
peut-être est-ce que c est ce que c'est
comment dire
peut-être le choix de la tête de liste
n'en sais rien ce que les lois et ce
qu'ils aient eu des choses qui n'ont pas
fonctionné cette fois ci mais c'est
clair qu'il faut se poser la question
pendant vraiment personne au conseil
général
et là il faudrait aux prochaines
cantonales qu'on essaie d'avoir cassé
si entre temps pas impressionnant ali le
gouvernement ne trouvera plus sa
majorité
du côté des socialistes c'est une
nouvelle claque même si dans le
département relativise le score du ps
n'est pas forcément moins bon qu'en 2009
on est un parti très pro européens mais
qui a pas suffit à mon avis dire à ces
cas l'europe qu'on voulait et à quel
point l'europe qui a actuellement en
place n'est pas celle que l'on veut donc
il ya une confusion entre le
fonctionnement de l'europe actuellement
et le s que portent les partis pro
européens il ya des messages qui ont été
qui ont été données la dimanche gens qui
se déplacent pas ils disent quelque
chose ce qu'ils viennent voter fn
on peut considérer qu'il ya un socle de
gens qui sont qui adhère vraiment aux
idées du front national
mais je pense que majoritairement c'est
le message c'est pas ça c'est un message
contre l'europe telle qu'elle fonctionne
actuellement et contre le système
politique en général en france contre
les partis politiques
donc ça il faut le prendre en compte
l'analyse et et puis ensuite apporter
les réponses et d'apporter les réponses
c'est forcément se remettre en cause il
faut en permanence aller voir les gens
sur le terrain voir nos concitoyens
discuter avec eux moi je crois vraiment
que pour réenchanter la politique il
faut aller discuter je pense que le
manque de dialogue aussi peut expliquer
un certain nombre de votes ce qui est
des incompréhensions quand on n'est pas
content on envoie un message qui est le
message aussi de contestation qui peut
être désamorcée si ce dialogue existe si
les échanges avec les élus existe et
pour analyser ces résultats nous avions
convié sur ce plateau le doyen honoraire
de la faculté de saint quentin en
yvelines faculté de droit voici
quelques-unes de ces réactions
l'intégralité de la séquence est à
revoir grâce au replay sur notre site
internet
en principe et sauf cas extraordinaires
l'europe ne mobilisera jamais les
élections européennes sont en effet
l'archétype même du processus électoral
considéré comme étant éloigné des
préoccupations quotidiennes
alors quand on veut taper dessus en
revanche on se mobilise un peu plus on
l'a vu
on l'a vu dimanche hier en revanche il
n'est pas si vous voulez
particulièrement étonnant que ce type de
scrutin ne mobilise pas autant que les
autres là plusieurs enquêtes qui essaye
de trouver les causes en tout cas qui
s'est abstenu lors de ce vote européen
ce sont les moins diplômés les plus
jeunes aussi c'est ce qui ressort de ces
enquêtes ça veut dire que l'europe que
les politiques aussi se coupent de la
france d'en bas sans être péjoratif
c'est un vaste sujet et c'est finalement
au coeur de du résultat de ces élections
c'est ce que les collègues chercheurs en
sciences politiques appellent le
désenchantement de la politique alors
qu'il ya des causes multiples et variées
ou de ce que même certains appellent une
phase post démocratique
je sais pas trop en quoi ça peut
consister la poste démocratie mais en
tout cas clairement oui il y a et on le
voit encore se soit enfin hier soir il y
a clairement une césure une coupure
entre eux ce qu'on pourrait appeler les
élites et le corps des citoyens le corps
des électeurs place et tout ce qu'on
appelle je n'aime pas ce terme là la
classe politique qui doit se remettre en
cause la classe politique parlementaire
républicaine qui doit absolument se
remettre en cause les choses vous disais
je pense ne sont pas du jour au
lendemain
il reste que cet état de décomposition
avancée désormais appel à un moment à un
autre une réaction lors une réaction
dans une forme de recomposition ne
serait-ce qu'une recomposition de la
géométrie de la structure des partis
politiques actuels
au lendemain des européennes c'est l'ump
qui était sur le devant de la scène et
chaque face au front national mais
surtout fausses factures et
surfacturations dans le cadre de la
campagne de nicolas sarkozy en 2012
la société de communication bygmalion
favorisée par jean-françois copé
il s'en défend make it sous la pression
la direction de son parti sur le plan
judiciaire les convocations se
multiplient car le quillier député des
yvelines a aussi été auditionnés par
l'office central de lutte contre la
corruption en tant que témoin libre il
interrogé afin de savoir s'il avait ou
non participer à une convention de l'ump
sur le thème de l'europe
le 2 juin 2012 une manifestation
présumées fictives il n'aurait en tout
cas selon ses déclarations aucun
souvenir qu'un tel événement et eu lieu
quel avenir pour l'ump nous avons posé
la question cette semaine à la constance
le grip eurodéputés d'île de france en
poste depuis 2010 c'était sur ce plateau
mardi soir est ce que l'ump peut
survivre à ce marasme
bien sûr que l'ump peut survivre et
l'ump doit survivre l'ump c'est le
rassemblement des familles politiques de
la droite et du centre droit
c'est une famille politique existe
depuis très très longtemps dans notre
pays que je considère comme utile à
notre pays à la démocratie est bien
évidemment l'ump va survivre et l'ump
doit survivre et nous allons tous
collectivement nous y employer qui pour
incarner l'ump aujourd'hui
qui souhaiteriez vous que sur quelles
lignes souhaitez-vous opposition alors
la ligne politique on va là déterminer
ensemble encore une fois on avoue une
femme
enfin bien sûr c'est qu'ils ont eux
mêmes les folies brutalement la sriw un
politique mais je pense que la priorité
des priorités c'est de mettre un peu de
sérénité et d'apaisement et de calmer
les tensions et de sortir des jeux de
personnes aidées du choc des ego qui de
manière générale font trop de mal à la
vie politique et font en ce moment trop
de mal à l'ump de la sérénité de
l'apaisement
une gouvernance collégiale qui se donne
pour tâche de préparer le congrès et qui
nous laissera le temps aux uns et aux
autres de travailler à forger une ligne
politique majoritaire génie ce qu'était
ma sensibilité
à moins que je partage avec d'autres une
sensibilité je dirais libéral
humaniste sociale et européennes autre
réaction que je vous propose de
découvrir à présent c'est celle de jean
michel fourgous le maire d'elancourt
secrétaire national de l'ump il n'hésite
pas à recadrer un autre député yvelinois
henri guaino qui ne s'est pas montré
très tendre avec sa famille politique
ces dernières semaines
monsieur guaino a d'énormes qualités
intellectuelles le d'écriture mais il
n'a aucune culture économique
s'il avait un minimum de culture
économique et qui voyait les entreprises
que c'est la première le premier
partenaire commercial quand même des
entreprises françaises l'europe que
c'est un tiers de nos emplois il
n'aurait pas dit toutes ces bêtises mais
cela dit j'aime bien en dehors de ça bon
voilà donc restons essence of dans quant
à l'ump bon le mp je vous dis à chaque
élection on attaque le président du
parti bon l'ump on l'a vu durant les
municipales on vient avec la même
histoire d'ailleurs quelques jours les 8
the run moi je ne sais pas je connais
pas ses dossiers il faut qu'on mette une
équipe qui fait gagner c'est la règle du
jeu est à la tête d'une entreprise on
est une équipe qui fait gagner tête d'un
parti aussi bon si monsieur
si monsieur copé est celui qui fait
gagner mais coûté faux faux le faut le
suivre et de maintenir si c'en est un
autre voilà c'est la règle du jeu je
n'ai pas de préférence particulière où
se lit j'ai une petite idée quand même
de vous à moi nous mêmes la demande est
pas mais j'ai une petite idée tout de
même deux qui va revenir les nouveaux
rythmes scolaires seront en place dès la
rentrée toujours pas de signes de recul
de la part du ministre benoît hamon qui
multiplie les déclarations à ce sujet et
pourtant ses opposants redoublent
d'efforts retour sur la manifestation
parisienne en fin de semaine dernière
avec ce reportage
il faut que cette réforme soit abrogée
point final il faut que le ministre ait
le courage d'abroger cette réforme une
réforme des rythmes scolaires toujours
vivement contesté samedi à paris une
manifestation nationale réunissait tout
un cortège de maires de communes
d'enseignants et de parents tous
mécontents des parents qui dénonce
clairement la fatigue de leurs enfants
avec une demi journée de plus à l'école
le mercredi et qui appellent au boycott
de la prochaine rentrée scolaire ya déjà
une maison un appel pour boycotter
carrément le jour de la rentrée c'est
bien au niveau des parents qu'au niveau
des enseignants et puis on peut y
comptera tous les mercredis 6 fomo
clairement je ne sacrifierai pas mes
enfants j'espère que monsieur peillon et
messieurs amour inscrivent leur nom à
l'histoire de l'éducation nationale
voilà les enfants sont frappe fatigué
n'est pas question de sacrifier côté mer
et enseignants pointent du doigt le coût
élevé de cette réforme sans pour autant
y trouver un intérêt pédagogique certain
les parents sont sont irrités les profs
sont démotivés
les maires sont sont soit fixé
économiquement comment peut-on balancer
une telle réforme avec un tel coût sans
aucune étude d'impact scientifique ni
financière alors qu'il s'agit de
l'avenir de nos enfants
je ne vois pas ce que ça peut apporter
aux enfants dans la mesure où on
réduirait le temps du midi
éventuellement d'un quart d'heure et le
temps du sort d'une des miens ne sait
pas dans ce temps là qu'on va faire de
l'activité intéressant pour les enfants
donc c'est nous mentir que nous dire que
les enfants vont avoir une activité
sportive ou culturelle
c'est un leurre prochain rendez vous des
anti réforme des rythmes scolaires le 11
juin avec une opération école vide
durant cette journée
le ministre de l'éducation benoît à
moins de son côté réaffirmé que la
réforme serait bien appliquée à la
rentrée prochaine le temps scolaire
n'étant pas décidé par les élus mais par
l'état et c'est maintenant le maire de
versailles françois de mazières qui
demandent le report de l'application de
ce décret il en appelle même aux
habitants de sa commune pour qu'ils
signent une pétition qui l'a mis en
ligne sur le site internet de la ville à
versailles il ya quelques années
existait un système qui fonctionnait
très bien c'est à dire qu'il y avait une
rythmes scolaires le samedi matin
un samedi sur deux et tout le monde
était content on a proposé de revenir à
ce système qui convenait bien à la fois
aux parents à la fois aux professeurs et
également nous sur le plan budgétaire
et qu'est ce que l'on voit c'est que
cette situation nous est refusé et donc
on se trouve avec une réforme qui est
imposée à nous qu est une réforme
extrêmement verrouillé de partout et je
dirais que en ce moment vraiment on a
besoin d'intelligence
on a besoin de calme on a besoin que les
finances publiques soient maîtrisés mais
je dis tout simplement versailles et
qu'ils témoignent de leur
incompréhension
nous aussi nous avons vraiment joué le
jeu je dois lui dire j'ai pris contact
personnellement avec le ministre en lui
expliquant puisque il est un ministre
des yvelines et député des yvelines je
lui dis vraiment voilà essayons d'être
intelligent semble ce qui me navre c'est
qu'il ya un décret tellement bloquant
qu'on ne peut pas être intelligent on ne
peut qu être dogmatique et ceci va à
l'encontre de l'intérêt des enfants de
l'intérêt des professeurs de l'intérêt
la collectivité puisque ça coûte pour
une ville comme versailles au minimum de
points d'impôt un nouvel épisode dans la
sphère du contrôle d'identité de la
femme voilée à trappes michael qui rit
le mari est condamné à 3 mois de pris
avec sursis pour s'être violemment
interposé lors du contrôle avait fait
appel de cette décision
il a été rejugé mardi devant la 7e
chambre correctionnelle du tribunal de
versailles
coup de théâtre un nouveau témoin des
faits s'est présenté à la barre une
femme habitant dans le quartier mermoz a
déclaré avoir vu à michael qui rit
stoïque
lors du contrôle ce qui va à l'encontre
des déclarations des trois policiers
concernés par cette affaire
le délibéré du jugement est prévu le 1er
juillet l'avocat général a requis la
confirmation des peines
la difficulté c'est de répondre à partir
d'un dossier que je n'ai pas eu de
commenter des commentaires que je lis
dans la presse
c'est toute la difficulté c'est la
raison pour laquelle j'ai demandé à ce
que certains documents nous soit
communiqué voilà pour faire la lumière
essayer de faire la lumière sur un
certain nombre de choses on a refusé
cette demande j'ai donc du à partir
des aliments des éléments mais en effet
ce témoignage a été à mon sens important
quelqu'un qui vient vous dire moi je ne
fais pas de politique
alors que tout l'environnement cas
autour de lui démontre qu'il ne fait à
son corps défendant
c'est pas lui qui fait c'est toujours
autour de lui ils ne font que de la
politique parce que qu'est ce qu'ils
demandent ils demandent l'application
dérogation de l'implication de certaines
règles de la république
c'est à dire que vous avez des gens qui
sont en l'occurrence des convertis et
deux et qui disent nous la loi de 2011
elle est contraire à la loi islamique
donc nous refusons les contrôles et pour
terminer cette édition nous revenons à
présent sur la situation des
agriculteurs d'ile-de-france leur
principal syndicat la fdsea
elle vient de tenir son assemblée
générale annuelle à louveciennes le mot
d'ordre pour les prochains mois reste le
même resté très actif
la fdsea la fédération départementale
des syndicats d'exploitants agricoles
d'île de france tenait son assemblée
générale à lucian hier l'occasion de
faire le bilan des actions menées cette
année un bilan en demi teinte
leur principal mobilisation a porté sur
l'aménagement de la pac la politique
agricole commune
les aides ont été remaniées cette année
la france a obtenu 63 milliards d'euros
pour les sept prochaines années
en novembre dernier la fdsea avait
organisé une grande mobilisation le
blocus de paris une action menée dans
l'ouest parisien pour défendre les
céréales y est alerté sur la sueur
fiscalisation des agriculteurs on a
quand même un peu la prétention de dire
que ces actions dures ont permis
d'atténuer on aurait pu aller encore
beaucoup plus loin la volonté du
ministre était d'aller encore beaucoup
plus loin vers une politique
décroissante effectivement là on a un
système compliqué qui va nous impacter
directement va nous impacter gravement
et va impacter gravement l'agriculture
francilienne
néanmoins nos actions permis peut-être
ne pas aller aussi loin que le mi5 visée
dans les yvelines les actions se sont
également portés sur les installations
illégales de campements de gens du
voyage un dialogue a été établi avec
cette communauté et les autorités
locales
enfin dernier point noir l'entretien des
cours d'eau et des fossés de drainage
traditionnellement effectué par les
agriculteurs eux-mêmes
il est aujourd'hui très encadrée par les
autorités pour minimiser l'action de
l'homme
aujourd'hui on sanctionne un agriculteur
à hauteur de 120 mille euros ou de trois
ans d'emprisonnement pour avoir cure et
un fossé ou un cours d'eau et ça ça nous
semble complètement ya pas de mots pour
le qualifier cc c'est complètement
aberrant
donc en fait il a fallu monter très
fortement au créneau par rapport à
l'administration met notamment à la
police de l'eau l'onema pour la
fédération qui représente les mines sans
exploitation agricole d'île de france
les politiques environnementales dans
leur ensemble vont à l'encontre d'un
maintien de la production fin de ce
journal du 30 mai rendez vous lundi dès
18h en direct 19h pour la première
rediffusion d'ici là les replays sont
sur notre site internet
et pour vos commentaires les réseaux
sociaux via le compte twitter de
téléphiles très bon week end